this is Eminem's holiday movie Guide
we're giving you our list of the best
holiday movies to enjoy on any occasion
whether it's the family the kids or that
special someone we have the perfect
holiday movies for you to enjoy while
the snow falls outside and you curl up
with a bowl of M&M so let's get started
for those of you wanting to tickle that
funny bone this holiday season there's
really no exception
National Lampoon's Christmas vacation
this is the ultimate Christmas comedy
starring Chevy Chase as earnest dad
Clark Griswold trying his best to give
his family the most amazing Christmas of
their lives
you've got highbrow comedy lowbrow
comedy and a squirrel coming out of a
tree what more could you ask for if
you're looking for more classic feel
this holiday season there's no better
film than Frank Capra's It's a Wonderful
Life
this life-affirming film has humour
heart emotion and a brilliant
performance by Jimmy Stewart they'll
leave you feeling good and appreciative
for this wonderful life our animated pic
is our third Christmas it's a story of
santa's youngest son and his urgent
christmas mission this modern classic
has a perfect mix of holiday high jinks
and sincere emotion that will pull your
heartstrings it also has an all-star
voice cast starring James McAvoy Hugh
Laurie and Eva Longoria if you're
looking for something more
family-friendly but still has something
for the adults there's Will Ferrell's
brilliant turn and funny and out there
are so many quotable classic lines from
this movie buddy the elf what's your
favorite color
Binda I know him sure listen anything
read that this is the definition of an
instant classic so cozy up with the
whole family and spread Christmas cheer
by singing loud for all to hear our
naughty pick is the holiday staple of
Christmas story this is actually a dark
comedy disguising itself as a cute and
fluffy film between getting tongue stuck
to poles a triple dog dare yeah and leg
lamps Brad
D la liste Italian this holiday pic has
the perfect amount of bite for those of
you who sense of humor leans towards the
more mean and mischievous also a fun
fact little Ralphie
play by Pierre Billingsley grew up to be
a big Hollywood hotshot producing movies
like Iron Man and four Christmases
that was Eminem's holiday movie Guide
thanks for watching leave a comment
below and let us know what your favorite
holiday movie is from all of us from
Eminem's
we wish you and yours a healthy and
happy holiday season
watching great movies while be curled up
with a bowl of milk chocolate goodness
is what the holidays is all about so
grab the M&M start the show